[Music]
let's go the jungle is where I'm from
there's no need to be afraid just don't
touch anything we're gonna die out here
or onto something big Dora an ancient
city made of gold what about that those
bad guys are after this get that map oh
we just have to get there first there's
no need to overreact so quick what
adults cry just don't know where to look
boots
[Music]
okay I'm gonna stop being surprised by
the things you're pulling out if your
backpack excuse me for dinner if you
think you know door she'll grow out of
it
think again adora this isn't the jungle
it's high school it's life or death
so if I don't talk to you don't take a
person okay well it's trying to survive
high schools a horrible nightmare are
you I'm glad you brought it I'm just
kidding I don't actually care we're onto
something big Dora an ancient city made
of gold we're gonna break some rules
we're coming with you Prima
[Music]
oh look barber on a knife on the field
trip everybody
it's a jungle puzzle
the jungle is perfectly safe
[Music]
seriously you had that in your backpack
too
Dora and the lost city of gold excuse me
hey chili con carne will be gee
you